okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the multiplication counting
principle now this is something they
test on the act and it's an easy one to
get right if you recognize it and let's
get right into it so basically what the
multiplication counting principle tells
us it tells us
how to find the total number of outcomes
and you can look at this a couple
different ways i'm going to show you
just kind of a visual way to understand
it and then just a quick way to solve
these problems so say for example you
know you had the choice of one of five
science classes
one of three language classes and one of
two math classes and you're going to
pick one of each right for your schedule
how many different schedules could you
create with one science class one
language class in one math class well
one way to visualize this is to make a
tree diagram so let's just look at the
math classes first so you could either
take you know math class number one or
math class number two right so it's kind
of like a you know fork in the row you
make a decision a tree diagram say you
pick math class number one
then you've got three choices for which
language class you take so maybe spanish
italian
or russian okay same thing here
spanish italian russian right
and then from there you could say well
you've got five choices for a science
class so one two three four five one two
three four five and so on
so if you were to draw this you could
see it could be quite large it would
take a long time to draw that
so a shorter method is just to take each
one of these choices okay each one of
the categories i should say and take the
number of choices in each category and
just multiply them all together so 5
times 3 is 15 times 2 is 30 and if you
were to draw this all out if you were to
count all the ends of these branches you
would end up with 30 different roots
essentially so that's the multiplication
counting principle in a nutshell you
multiply the number of
choices in each category together and
that's going to give you the total
number of outcomes so let's look at this
example here see if you can do it on
your own i think you've got it but we'll
go through it here
you go to a restaurant and have the
option of one of two appetizers right
one of five entrees and one of three
desserts how many meals are possible if
you pick one appetizer one entree and
one dessert
okay so you can see
all we have to do is multiply the two
appetizers times the five entrees times
the three desserts and you can see we're
getting in this case 30 which is just a
coincidence with that initial example
that i gave you so that's all you do is
you multiply them together and that
gives you the total number of outcomes